as a beauty blogger it's really
difficult for me to get empties even if
I really love a product I just don't get
enough time in between trying out new
products to finish up old products I
also have this really bad habit of
keeping a tiny bit of my favorite
products at the bottom of the container
just in case I know it's really stupid
and I should just finish it up and buy a
new one and have lots more of that
product to use but it's a habit that
I've had since my starving student days
so any empties are a massive achievement
and it means that I really really like
the product ivory purchased all of the
ones I'm going to show you guys today
I am completely in love with ultra
sitacles daily moisturizer it has
everything going for it except suppose
it's been really difficult for me to
find a sunscreen that fits all my
criteria it has to be not too greasy it
can't give me clogged pores it has to
have high protection and it has to be
budget-friendly and the only thing wrong
with this one is that it's quite
expensive it's only SPF 30 but because
of the lightweight non-greasy texture it
goes on thick enough that I end up with
enough protection I've been using it
almost every day for more than six
months and even though I don't apply
exactly 1/4 TSP to my face I get enough
protection that I found that some spots
and acne marks have been fading really
quickly in terms of sunscreen filters it
has the newest photostable UVA filter to
nosov s along with dr. Knox 8 ever been
zone ultra Kryolan and ins always all
other do interval ingredients that's got
silica which Marcia fires and makes it
less greasy niacinamide which helps her
fade hyperpigmentation and soak up UV
damage and hyaluronic acid which hydrate
skin the pump dispenser is also really
handy I haven't cut it open yet to get
out the final bits though the price is
the worst aspect $74 per hundred mils
which are 25% more than la roche-posay
in Australia but I've tried a lot of
sunscreens and none of them have worked
quite as well as this one I haven't
tried many SPF 30 once though because I
didn't think they work as well as SPF 50
until I tried this one I'm still looking
for a more budget-friendly one which
hits all my criteria but this one's the
closest so far
my favorite types of makeup remover are
the ones that are two-phase they look a
bit like oil sitting on water I bought a
whole bunch of Korean ones awhile ago
and the attitude house with an eye
remover ended up being my favorite it
removes my makeup effectively in a
couple of swipes without leaving behind
a greasy layer and it's super cheap
niño day photography fluid is a liquid
that has lots of shimmering particles in
it and I've been wearing it almost every
day under my foundation and I'm actually
wearing it right now
it is ritu sparkly and it's quite yellow
which suits my skin really well it makes
my face look glowy when I mix it in with
foundation or even underneath foundation
there's also achieve a highly made
version that's similar that doesn't look
quite as good on me
the one thing I really don't like about
this product is the dropper bottle I
lose so much product on the neck
shakin tuition raises are raises that
have four blades and they come with a
chunk of sofa touch so that they lather
up as you shave the heads have this cool
mechanism that makes the razor blades
level with the slope when you put it
against your skin no matter how much so
if you've used their more expensive and
they don't shave quite as closely as a
regular razor but they're so convenient
that I always end up using them
I use these cotton pads from Daiso
mostly for eye makeup removal I cut them
in half and use one side for each eye if
my makeup isn't too heavy they stay
together really well don't leave any
fluff on your skin and have no rough
bits there two dollars a tea for two
boxes of ninety from Daiso and that's my
latest empties what reviews do you guys
want to see from me let me know in the
comments if you like my videos please
subscribe thanks for watching and I'll
see you again soon
[Music]